- I do however, have
for you a proposition.
(birds chirping)
You take the hand of
my daughter, Catherine,
in marriage.
(joyful orchestral music)
(wood creaking)
(footsteps thumping)
(speaks in foreign language)
(coughing)
(footsteps thumping)
(distant crowd shouting)
(speaks in foreign language)
(distant bell tolling)
- May as much I wonder
about a great many things.
- Indeed there must be for
you to contemplate marriage
to a woman about whom you know so little.
- Mm.
- I will not submit to you.
You must earn my respect.
- I understand that.
- Do you?
- [Man] I do.
- Do you feel a sense of achievement?
- In what regard?
- [Catherine] In any regard.
- I have achieved that
which my father never could.
I have united this
kingdom in common cause.
- Hmm.
You have achieved momentary respite.
A unity forged under false pretense
will never be a unity that prevails.
- How, pray, have my
endeavors been forged falsely?
- Why did you bring war to France?
- Your father came on spoiling.
- Oh, so how was he spoiling?
- He sent an assassin.
- There was no assassin.
There was no plot to kill you.
- How might you know?
- Because I was with my father
when you received word of your charge.
I know him well enough to know
his reaction to be genuine.
- How was his reaction?
- He laughed.
He laughed very much.
He said you must be drunk.
- Your father's a madman.
- He may be mad, but he's true.
His madness makes him true.
This is only what he believes.
That is why he is loved.
- The assassin then was
sent by your brother.
- [Catherine] My brother?
- Mm-Hmm.
- My brother was too stupid
to conjure such a plan.
What was your true reason?
- Did you know of the ball he sent?
The ball he sent to me?
- A ball?
He sent to you a ball?
- Why should you question my intent?
Your father's rule is illegitimate.
He has not right claim to his throne.
- All monarchy is illegitimate.
You yourself are the son of a usurper.
It would seem that you have no explanation
for what you have done.
You have shed the blood
of so many Christian souls and yet,
before me now, all I see
is a young and vain and
foolish man so easily riled.
So easily beguiled.
- I must leave you now.
(slow dramatic orchestral music)
(wood creaking)
(footsteps thumping)
(distant crowd shouting)
(crowd speaking in foreign language)
- My liege.
- I ask nothing of you.
Only that you will always
speak to me clear and true.
Always.
Will you promise me only that?
(crowd chanting)
- I will.
(dramatic orchestral music)
- [Crowd] Praise Henry!
Praise Henry!